welcome back to Las Vegas now do you
know that a certificate account can earn
you a higher dividend Mercedes found out
from Silver State school's Credit Union
the sponsors of this next segment take a
look
I love when I get to talk to the
president and CEO of Silver State
Schools Credit Union Scott oracles
welcome back to the show Scott how you
doing good Mercedes how are you doing
so good I have not made it a secret I am
a member of Silver State Schools Credit
Union so are my daughters and as as
adults we teach our kids to save their
money and put it in their piggy bank but
as adults something I'm learning at
Silver State Schools Credit Unions is
that you have a bunch of savings options
and one of them is a certificate account
can you tell us what that is sure
Mercedes well we know that educating
students on financial habits at an early
age is very very important and we know
that having these positive habits are
going to actually create a success
through a lifetime to to get you to
financial success really uh and where
you want to be so popular savings option
is actually known as a certificate
account and that allows you to select a
period of time generally between 3 and
60 months where you agree to withdraw
the funds
um now in return what you get is a
higher dividend rate and uh and and
that's known as an annual percentage
rate also known as an apy and so uh our
certificate counts are a great account
to help you save for long-term goals um
because you do keep them in in the top
for a longer period of time because
you're getting that higher savings rate
and uh um and just think of the
long-term goals of things like a home
down payment or retirement that type of
thing
I love that idea it's such a good idea
and right now Silver State Schools
Credit Union are you guys offering any
sorts of special certificate account
promotions through the end of September
right now Silver State Schools Credit
Union is offering a 30-month certificate
account the returns 2.25 annual
percentage still
um and that's where the minimum deposit
about 500 and so
um and I will tell you this is one of
the best dividend rates that I've seen
in the region in fact I I did see uh one
other one in California when I was there
recently and it was not quite as
attractive as ours and so
um if it's a great promotion and one
that we that certainly uh would
encourage members and and non-members
who want to become members of ours uh to
certainly invest in and so details are
available by visiting
silverstatecu.com or by visiting any one
of our 10 branches you love the kids at
Silver State Credit Union and the last
time that we talked you were talking
about the 2023 Happy Times Calendar
student artwork contest do they still
have time to submit their artwork
there's no time for the students and in
grade K-12 to submit artwork uh
depicting what makes them happy winning
uh submissions will be showcased in our
upcoming 2023 Happy Times Calendar
give them a call or just visit
silverstatescreditunion.com or excuse me
silverstatecu.com we'll be right back
here